i don't think there's ever been a better
player to put on the reds uniform
he could do everything
he was the best hitter
on the team
he was the best base runner on the team
he was a gold glove defender
he played second base a premium position
and
he most importantly he was loved by his
teammates and on this 8 8 21
throughout the broadcast we will
remember number eight and we hope to
give his life justice a life that is so
so missed
career-high marks in wins and strikeouts
oh and he buries it bottom third called
strike three
and reynolds who's one of the better
bats in the game this year
he's fought off a series of foul balls
and he goes down on strikes
[Applause]
well he mentioned why that high fastball
is so important
get the eyesights up there and then all
of a sudden he drops that split
there goes hayes swing and a miss down
goes murray
three k's in the first inning for tyler
o'malley
[Applause]
oh two
call strike three four k's for tyler
maui
[Applause]
popped him up longer run for suarez
thanks to the shift into foul ground
makes the catch as he hits the warning
track
just a little here you go contact make a
little contact here and there and
get off the mountain
the case will play too
he's got five through his first couple
of innings
bryce wilson came over from atlanta
richard rodriguez trained enough messing
around says bryce he has his first
strikeout as a pirate
to see her see the movement catching
middle of the plate
stevenson perhaps expecting another
breaking ball
oh
struck about
back back-to-back strikeouts for mr
wilson
now we haven't seen too many poor
at-bats from farmer in this series that
[Applause]
definitely not one of his better ones
looks like robbie on an airplane
bryce wilson strikes out the side
[Music]
straight up on the infield very shallow
in the outfield for the reds and it
won't matter swinging a miss strike
three
and through the first nine malley
strikes out six of those nine batters
the line that really cracks is
joe is the greatest second baseman of
all time
and that he believes he is the greatest
red
of all time now he gets to swing into
this his seventh strikeout as hayes goes
down
reynolds slicing one toward the corner
he's gonna have extra bases
that's a double for brian reynolds here
with one out in the fourth
he was talking about his time
in indianapolis and they let him play
down there for more than two months too
it wasn't just
get hot for a couple weeks and come up
go ahead go ahead that eludes two reds
and reynolds will scramble in to score
the game's first run
a costly mistake for cincinnati
anything can happen i mean he's over
there in time i mean we'll take it it's
a slowly hit ball just bend over and
catch it
you slide and you kick it in the left
you cause your pitcher a run they're
probably scoring a hit two because you
slid you stay on your feet you make the
play you're out of the inning
putting in hours putting in time with
these young men and women and we'll be
rooting on the softball rbi team as well
as that ball gets away
and castiano's on his way to second base
weaker will stop at third
they're here to watch him today
and he smashes it to right center field
off the wall
winker scores stop sign castellanos
joey volo ties the game
well this is probably one of the hardest
hit and longest furthest
singles
you will ever see
this ball was blistered
by joey vado
grounded right side double play ball
will mean a run tall throw no chance in
a relay
castillato scores stevenson strides
through safely reds lead 2-1 on the
fielder's choice
shadows roll
farmer to right center that's going to
get down
stevenson through second all the way to
the wall wave is on for stevenson
park eats it stevenson crosses standing
kyle former clubs an rbi double
three one
kyle farmer just keeping the line going
lay kick
good balance
hitting the ball well and the big fella
tyler stevenson picking them up putting
them down
when they make the plaque they break the
mold
and
there won't be another one
now from the belt turns it loose and
strike three called got him looking
that's the same pitch he punched him out
onto the first inning a fastball at the
knees nine strikeouts for tyler malley
yeah you got to have style i don't know
how to wear one like that
head out to deep center
and hayes has left the yard a home run
out front at 92.
and that's where i think keith bryant i
mean he's done such a good job last year
but the contact point
hitting that ball to basically straight
away center field on a pitch on the
inner third of the plate
spin something off the plate
let's keep pounding them in that one
left middle again
wraps it up
[Applause]
right place right time the lean you just
know that he's gonna make another diving
catch it's just so
routine anymore the last week ten days
it's like he's made eight or nine of
these
[Music]
95 96 up in the zone
you got to get there
so you have to commit to it
and then this breaking ball
is tough to cover
swing and a miss
[Music]
that is double-digit strikeouts for
tyler malley for the sixth time in his
career
what are you gonna do
that time it wasn't the split that time
it was the slider
kyle farmer the rage sweep the pirates
and they get the win on joe morgan day
in cincinnati
[Applause]